[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit gundula
gause und bettina schausten
guten abend noch hat sich die ampel als
neue regierung nicht gefunden die detail
verhandlungen begannen heute erst
zeitgleich präsentierten sich die drei
partner aber schon einig in sachen
corona die epidemische notlage rechtlich
die grundlage für scharfe maßnahmen die
lok downs soll ende november auslaufen
eine übergangsregelung den ländern die
möglichkeit geben zu weiteren
schutzmaßnahmen bis der winter
überstanden ist angesichts steigender
inzidenz 'nen auch heute wieder
erscheint dies manchem ein gefährliches
signal aus berlin heike slansky
diese bilder soll es künftig nicht mehr
geben keine schulschließungen keine
ausgangssperren keinen lockt am schluss
mit den drastischen grundrechts
einschränkungen die ampel partner wollen
in der pandemie neue wege gehen die
gesamte bandbreite an krone
schutzmaßnahmen für anwendbar erklären
zu lassen war für uns jedenfalls keine
option wir werden jetzt einen
überschaubaren katalog wenig eingriffs
intensiver maßnahmen zur verfügung
stellen und alle maßnahmen enden
spätestens mit dem frühlingsbeginn am 20
märz
die bundesrechtliche grundlage die
sogenannte epidemische lage von
nationaler tragweite
hochumstritten soll nun nach 20 monaten
ende november auslaufen
stattdessen sollen nur noch wenige
maßnahmen gelten zum beispiel das tragen
von masken in innenräumen 3g geimpft
gewesen oder test nachweis hygiene
konzepte für betriebe veranstaltungen
oder einrichtungen der
instrumentenkasten steht zur verfügung
so dass die bundesländer entsprechende
maßnahmen einleiten können aber eben
nicht mehr das was wir vorher gesagt
haben so was wie schließungen von ganzen
einrichtungen aus dem kanzleramt heißt
es angela merkel sorge sich wegen der
steigenden infektionszahlen vergangene
woche erst protestierten einige
ministerpräsidenten forderten eine klare
rechtsgrundlage
wir sehen wie sich die zahlen jetzt
entwickeln insofern glaube ich schon
dass man auch weiter besonnen mit dieser
situation umgehen muss wenn es aber
keine mehrheit mehr gibt für diese
notlagen regelung die irgendwann ja
tatsächlich auch auslaufen muss ist dann
aber das mindeste dass wir brauchen eine
übergangsregelung er wäre es wird sich
nicht an ein datum halten wichtig ist
wir wollen alle normalität wir wollen
alle keine lockdown mehr aber wir wollen
vorsichtig sein und die menschen
schützen das ist der maßstab das muss
uns leiten und das wollen wir gemeinsam
ende der korona notlage die impfquote
etwa vier von fünf erwachsenen geschützt
rechtfertige keinen weiteren
ausnahmezustand auch keine verordnungen
von oben in kleinen runden künftig
entscheidet wieder das parlament das ist
glaube ich ein gutes zeichen für die
demokratie und sicherlich auch ein
beitrag um das vertrauen der bürgerinnen
und bürger in die politik
zurückzugewinnen
neue zeiten brechen an in berlin der
erste beschluss möglicher
regierungspartner eine mehrheit im
bundestag hätten sie bereits
ja aber einen koalitionsvertrag steht
aus der weg dahin führt das schauen wir
uns nochmal an über 22 fach
arbeitsgruppen mit insgesamt rund 300
teilnehmern seit heute bis zum 10
november wird verhandelt danach tagen
die chefinnen und chefs und räumen
ungelöstes ab der koalitionsvertrag soll
dann bis ende november stehen und dann
von den gremien der parteien bestätigt
werden wenn das alles so klappt könnte
ab dem 6 dezember die neue
bundesregierung vereidigt und im
anschluss auch ein neuer bundeskanzler
gewählt werden soweit also der plan der
eu was war denn das heute in berlin zum
thema corona die ampel übt schon mal das
regieren bevor sie überhaupt regierung
ist ja im prinzip ist es ein sehr
schnelles klar machen wer jetzt die
macht hat im neuen bundestag haben die
ampel parteien die mehrheit und sie
machen entsprechend die ansage wir im
parlament haben ein inhaltliches konzept
zur stilllegung dieses jahr sehr stark
kritisierten paragrafen 28a des
infektionsschutzgesetzes vorgelegt und
du verehrter geschäftsführender
gesundheitsminister mars daraus jetzt
ein gesetzentwurf im grunde hat damit
die ampel regierung erstmals die
parlamentarische bühne betreten frau
göring-eckardt hat es ja heute auch in
dem spruch zusammengefasst die ampel
funktioniert bevor sie gibt in jedem
fall ist es aber auch ein signal dass
die drei ampel parteien nicht mehr am
zustandekommen ihrer koalition zweifel
ja und der druck dass es jetzt auch
wirklich klappt ist noch mal höher
geworden was hört man denn nun von tag 1
offenbar ließ jetzt nicht nur ganz glatt
das stimmt aber man muss sich das
natürlich auch vorstellen da verhandeln
fast 300 der führenden bundespolitiker
miteinander die meisten sind der
hochgradig vernetzt auch mit uns medien
und so gut wie nichts dringt nach
draußen heute aber gab es dann ein
erstes hörbares knirschen in dieser jahr
diskreten stille der generalsekretär der
fdp wissing hat grüne und spd davor
gewarnt wieder in den wahlkampf modus zu
verfallen so meinte er stolz und hatten
die liberalen ja kritisiert sie seien
daran schuld dass untere
einkommensgruppen steuerlich nicht
entlastet werden könnten letztlich
glaube ich sind solche rangeleien auch
ein beleg dafür wie schwierig die frage
der finanzen insgesamt sein dürfte denn
es geht schlicht um eine quadratur des
kreises einerseits seine eingehaltene
schuldenbremse und nicht steigende
steuern und andererseits hunderte
milliarden für zusätzliche investitionen
ohne bisher sagen zu können wo die
herkommen sollen ampeln stehen ja gerne
mal vor kreuzungen und noch ist
zumindest mein geld nicht klar erkennbar
welchen der unterschiedlichen wege die
neue koalition einschlagen wird wir sind
gespannt wie es weitergeht dankeschön
theo koll nach berlin
armin laschet hat wort gehalten seit
gestern ist der gescheiterte
kanzlerkandidat der union einfacher
abgeordneter im deutschen bundestag sein
amt als cdu vorsitzender hat er
ausgeschrieben und ministerpräsident von
nordrhein westfalen ist heute ein
anderer hendrik wüst holte trotz
knappster mehrheit der schwarz gelben
regierung im ersten wahlgang die nötigen
stimmen und sollte sein vorgänger
nochmals respekt in laschet tradition
wolle er weitermacht leicht werden wird
das nicht aus düsseldorf dort ferber
zählappell in der cdu fraktion an diesem
morgen auch abgeordnete mit beinbruch
müssen kommen jede einzelne stimme wird
zur wahl des neuen ministerpräsidenten
gebraucht
dem alten ministerpräsidenten wird in
düsseldorfer landtag heute gedankt
fangen laschet hält seine letzte rede
hier
die auf diese art und weise
verabschieden von der landespolitik es
war mir eine freude war mir eine ehre
glückauf und gottes segen für unser land
nordrhein westfalen
dann zittert hendrik wüst um seine wahl
von den gültigen stimmen stimmten mit ja
103 um die erleichterung ist groß
gewählt im ersten wahlgang trotz äußerst
knapper mehrheit der schwarz gelben
regierungskoalition
nordrhein westfalens ministerpräsident
heißt jetzt hendrik wüst
ich will gemeinsam mit meinem kabinett
die dinge vorantreiben und neues angehen
und dabei auch über das jahr 2022 hinaus
denken für eine politik die an die
nächste generation denkt und nicht nur
an die nächste wahl
zuspitzen und forscher so beginnt wüst
seine karriere in der landespolitik
2006 wird der generalsekretär der cdu
nrw tritt später zurück weil bekannt
wird dass die partei gesprächstermine
mit dem damaligen ministerpräsidenten
rüttgers an unternehmen verkauft
2017 wüst karriere wieder fahrt auf als
nrw-verkehrsminister im kabinett laschet
als ministerpräsident warten nun neue
aufgaben auf den 46-jährigen die
opposition formuliert sie schon mal
nervös muss erst mal seine rolle selbst
finden ist ja noch der alte scharfmacher
wie wir ihn alle in nordrhein westfalen
als generalsekretär kennen das wäre
keine gute rolle für einen landesvater
wir sind derzeit in einer corona phase
die durchaus sehr kritisch wieder ist
das heißt auch hier braucht es eine
handlungsfähige landesregierung es geht
auch noch mal die impfkampagne auch mehr
nach vorne zu bringen politik für die
nächste generation will wüst also machen
er selbst ist seit einigen monaten erst
mal zur vater und er will politik über
die nächste wahl hinaus machen die es
den gut einem halben jahr wüsts amtszeit
könnte da auch kurz seien in nrw sind
die umfragen für die cdu derzeit
schlecht
und nun können wir ihn kennen lernen
hendrik wüst neuer ministerpräsident von
nordrhein-westfalen schönen abend so
wurden verschossen ihr wisst wie groß
war der stein der ihnen von herzen viel
als es heute im ersten anlauf klappte
doch ich habe auf die aussagen der
fraktionen von cdu und fdp vertraut und
wir haben gesehen ich konnte vertrauen
aber natürlich ist man dann auch schon
erleichtert die cdu fraktion hat
gestanden der cdu parteitag am
wochenende hatten mehr als 98 prozent
beschert ist ja ein ergebnis das fast
schon eine bürde ist
finden
finden die sie jetzt alle so toll herr
wüst oder ist es vor allem ausdruck von
angst ein halbes jahr vor der wahl bloß
kein streit zu produzieren es ist
ausdruck davon dass die menschen in
nordrhein-westfalen sich auf die cdu
verlassen können wir sind einig
geschlossen und stark wie ihre gehen und
nordrhein westfalen gemeinsam mit den
liberalen die einzig christlich liberale
koalition in deutschland wir gehen gut
und gerne und das soll so bleiben dass
die liberalen in abhandenkommen das
befürchten sie nicht im bund gehen die
ja jetzt mal an die seite der spd
in nordrhein-westfalen haben wir heute
sehr klar und deutlich gezeigt dass hier
niemand abhanden kommt die koalition hat
gestanden die fraktionen haben ihre
stimmen gemeinsam bei meiner wahl
gebracht und wir haben noch gemeinsam
eine ganze menge vor für nordrhein
westfalen jetzt müssen sie eigentlich
schon in den wahlkampf einsteigen im mai
wird gewählt und die gefahr dass sie da
schon wieder scheitern ist ja durchaus
real die umfragen sind schlecht es gibt
genügend beispiele wo es auch genauso
schlecht lief ich erinner mal an david
mcallister in niedersachsen übernahmen
der auf halber strecke wurde dann nicht
gewählt stefan mappus in
baden-württemberg übernahm wurde nicht
gewählt in nrw sie kennen das beispiel
peer steinbrück alle blieben
eintagsfliegen könnte man sagen wie
wollen sie das verhindern
erst mal in dem wir gar keinen wahlkampf
machen sondern regieren dafür sind wir
da die das land gut zu regieren für die
menschen da zu sein und wir haben eine
ganze menge große themen auf der agenda
die wiederaufbau thematik in den
flutgebieten
corona ist auch in diesem winter hat
noch immer ein thema da müssen wir
weiter aufpassen sehr sehr wachsam sein
wir haben das große thema klimaschutz im
industrieland nordrhein-westfalen
zwingend zu verbinden mit guten
arbeitsplätzen in der industrie hier ist
überhaupt kein raum für wahlkampf wir
haben eine menge zu tun so ist das sie
übernehmen nämlich jetzt die führung des
bevölkerungsreichsten bundesland und
müssen sich ja ab sofort eben nicht mehr
nur um ihr ressort verkehr sondern um
das gesamtwohl kümmern inklusive corona
strategie sie haben es angesprochen
einige ministerpräsident üben ja heute
kritik an der entscheidung der ampel
vertreter die epidemische lage zu
beenden obwohl die zahlen steigen haben
sie sich dazu schon eine meinung
gebildet finden sie das gut oder
schlecht
die ampel parteien wollen ist so und sie
haben eine mehrheit im bund sie wollen
die epidemische lage von nationaler
tragweite eben nicht mehr beschließen
unsere forderung der länder unter dem
vorsitz des landes nordrhein westfalen
bei der ministerpräsidentenkonferenz war
dass man trotzdem einen verlässlichen
rechtsrahmen schafft dass wir gut durch
diesen winter kommen sicher durch diesen
winter kommen ich habe die ankündigung
vernommen dass man diesen rechtsrahmen
schaffen will aber da müssen wir jetzt
schon genau darauf schauen die details
sind da wichtig da gibt es eine eigene
stelle durchaus zweifel armin laschet
wurde immer mal wieder vorgeworfen in
sachen corona sei er zu sehr einem zick
zack kurs gefolgt sie haben ja heute
gesagt sie wollten seiner tradition
folgen auch bei diesem thema
in der korona politik ist wichtig dass
wir so viel sicherheit schaffen wie
möglich mit so wenig
grundrechtseingriffen wie nötig das ist
die philosophie hier in nordrhein
westfalen das ist die idee mit der wir
in den letzten 19 monaten an das thema
herangegangen sind und ich halte das
nach wie vor auch für richtig das so zu
machen aber es wird viel davon abhängen
für ihre wahl wie sie gerade das corona
thema natürlich stemmen letzte frage
wollen sie eigentlich direkt an gerne
mit einem neuen kanzler verhandeln so
wie das in der vergangenheit war wenn
das olaf scholz würde hätte der
vielleicht gar nicht so viel interesse
daran sie übernehmen ja jetzt den
vorsitz der ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
ich glaube es hat sich bewährt dass
bundesregierung und länder in dem format
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz gemeinsam
diese dinge lösen es muss möglich sein
auch über partei und fraktionsgrenzen
hinweg in solche wesentlichen fragen wie
der korona pandemie zusammenzuarbeiten
ich bin dazu jedenfalls bereit
vielen dank herr bist danke ihnen
das gespräch haben wir aus termingründen
am abend aufgezeichnet und jetzt weitere
nachrichten mit gundula gause in den usa
könnten anders als in deutschland schon
bald auch kinder zwischen fünf und elf
jahren gegen das corona virus geimpft
werden für eine notfall zulassung des
impfstoffs von bayern takt pfizer hat
sich ein beratergremium der
arzneimittelbehörde fdp ausgesprochen
die empfehlung ist zwar nicht bindend in
der regel aber folgt die fdp dem rat der
fachleute eine endgültige entscheidung
wird noch in dieser woche erwartet
das 12 milliarden schwere corona
sondervermögen des landes hessen ist
verfassungswidrig
der hessische staatsgerichtshof
entschied damit habe die schwarz grüne
landesregierung ihre
haushaltsrechtlichen kompetenzen
überschritten hessen hatte als einziges
bundesland ein kredit finanziertes
sondervermögen beschlossen um die
finanziellen herausforderungen der
korona krise zu bewältigen die
opposition hatte dies als
schattenhaushalt kritisiert
vor der zweiten tarifverhandlungsrunde
für die beschäftigten im öffentlichen
dienst der länder außer hessen hat es in
hamburg erste warnstreiks gegeben dazu
aufgerufen hatte die gewerkschaft wäre
die fünf prozent mehr gehalt monatlich
aber mindestens 150 euro mehr so die
forderung der gewerkschaften die
arbeitgeber bezeichnen das als überhöht
sollte es eine einigung geben könnte sie
für rund 35 millionen menschen gelten
iran wird die atomverhandlungen in wien
im november wieder aufnehmen
diplomatische vorgespräche in brüssel
seien sehr konstruktiv gewesen erklärte
irans vize-außenminister mit denen immer
wieder unterbrochenen verhandlungen soll
verhindert werden dass teheran
atomwaffen baut iran geht es zugleich um
die aufhebung von us sanktionen die das
land in eine schwere wirtschaftskrise
geführt haben
die usa fordern weiterhin die
auslieferung von julian assange in
london hat das berufungsverfahren
begonnen vor dem gerichtsgebäude
forderten anhänger die freilassung des
inhaftierten
wikileaks-gründers im januar hatte ein
londoner gericht die auslieferung
abgelehnt wegen dessen angegriffener
gesundheit und der zu erwartenden
haftbedingungen in den usa wegen
spionagevorwürfen will die us justiz den
50 jährigen australier den prozess
machen ihm droht lebenslange haft
der streit zwischen polen und der eu
kommission über die polnische justiz
rüffer und spitzt sich weiter zu und
wird für polen teuer ein tägliches
zwangsgeld von einer million euro
verhängte heute der europäische
gerichtshof solange polen die umsetzung
eines urteils aus dem sommer missachte
angerufen hatte das gericht die
eu-kommission die es bisher nicht
schaffte die polen zu disziplinieren und
von ihrem nationalen kurs abzubringen
der die unabhängigkeit von justiz und
medien mehr und mehr untergräbt bonner
krüger aus brüssel
kaum ein wort aus der kommission nicht
zum kriegsgeheul aus warschau nicht zum
donnerwetter aus luxemburg doch wann
wenn nicht jetzt
es ist ein entscheidender moment im
streit zwischen der eu und der
polnischen regierung keiner kann oder
darf sich darin jetzt zurückzieht
richter in luxemburg europas höchste
spitzen den streit heute zu eine million
euro eine pro tag um schaden abzuwenden
von werten auf denen die union gegründet
wurde richter in polen wären sind die
opfer gegängelt von einer
disziplinarkammer am obersten gericht
sichtbares zeichen eines schleichenden
umbaus es geht hier im kern darum ob die
urteile umgesetzt werden empfohlen und
das eben auch auf diesen sehr wichtigen
zentralen bereich der unabhängigkeit der
justiz
justiz unsere sache sagte ein sprecher
der weg der bestrafung und der pressung
gegenüber unserem land ist nicht der
richtige weg
und sein premier warnt die eu vor einem
weltkrieg setzt im streit seinen rahmen
nicht polen verletze die justiz die eu
überschreite ihre macht
die eu ist kein staat kein super staat
das haben wir nicht vereinbart
das teilt bislang nur ungarn doch es
könnten mehr werden vor allem in
osteuropa diese beiden regierungen
versuchen auch noch die die begriffe
innerhalb der europäischen union zu
verändern also wie in der europäischen
union rechtsstaatlichkeit und demokratie
definiert und verstanden wird und das
ist unglaublich gefährlich so sehen das
auch regierungschefs vor allem in
westeuropa
airplane sie spielen mit dem feuer wenn
sie aus innenpolitischen gründen krieg
gegen ihre europäischen kollegen führen
unsere union ist eine union der werte
kein geld auto macht sie können nicht
das geld einstecken und die werte
ablehnen
europas werte retten die spaltung meiden
es kommt auf eine kanzlerin an die
europa schon ag sagte der kompromiss
wäre europäisch und manche meinen vmm
izmir dummy polens regierung hoffe dass
die eu kommission in diesem streit
zurückweicht und mit kosmetischen
änderungen zufrieden ist das wird die
kommission dann als erfolg verkünden sie
wird das geld das dem aufbau von leben
und der konflikt
um zu sagen was sie macht hatte die
kommission heute einen tag zeit und hat
ihn verstreichen lassen
und nun noch einmal nachrichten gundula
gause
die führungsspitze einer möglichen
künftigen ampelkoalition war zu gast bei
der industriegewerkschaft bergbau chemie
energie
spd-kanzlerkandidat scholz versprach
dabei mehr tempo beim umbau hin zu
klimaneutralität auch fdp-chef lindner
setzte sich für schnellere
genehmigungsverfahren ein grünen co
vorsitzende baerbock forderte dabei
europäische lösungen und auch cdu-chef
laschet war zu gast er würdigte die
bemühungen um einen sozialverträglichen
kohleausstieg und kritisierte zugleich
das angepeilte frühere auslaufen der
kohleverstromung schon 2030
auch wegen der weltweit hohen
energiepreise hat die bundesregierung
ihre konjunkturprognose für dieses jahr
deutlich nach unten korrigiert von 3,5
prozent wie im frühjahr erwartet auf
aktuell 2,6 prozent frank bethmann dazu
corona und liefert krise boomen soll die
wirtschaft dann wieder im nächsten jahr
wie realistisch ist das schwer zu sagen
wir haben in den letzten anderthalb
jahren erlebt was alles passieren kann
die chancen für stärkeres wachstum
stehen nicht schlecht die unsicherheiten
aber sind groß keiner kann heute mit
sicherheit sagen wie sich das mit den
lieferproblemen oder mit den
energiepreisen weiterentwickelt auch
nicht der scheidende
bundeswirtschaftsminister peter altmaier
die inflation betonte er heute noch mal
sei nur ein vorübergehendes phänomen
doch zweifel bleiben wenn man auf die
preisentwicklung für importierte waren
schaut
bearbeitetes holz verteuerte sich
innerhalb nur eines jahres um 65% der
preis für roheisen und stahl stieg um 61
prozent den vogel aber schoss das erdgas
ab um sage und schreibe 100 71 prozent
verteuerte sich der energieträger
innerhalb von nur zwölf monaten
die importpreise steigen insgesamt so
stark wie seit 1981 nicht mehr
passenderweise dem jahr nach der zweiten
ölkrise
wieder sind ist vor allem die
energiepreise die für exorbitante
preissprünge sorgen und die
gewerkschaften auf den plan rufen
gemeinsam mit der ig metall ruft eben
jene ig bce am freitag zu
demonstrationen im gesamten bundesgebiet
auf die beiden groß gewerkschaften
fordern den strom radikal zu verbilligen
und gas benzin weniger zu besteuern
frank bethmann vielen dank eine meldung
vom sport der zweite teil der zweiten
runde im dfb pokal läuft in folgenden
schon beendeten partien haben sich die
sieger fürs achtelfinale qualifiziert
und für überraschung gesorgt denn bayer
leverkusen verlor gegen den karlsruher
sc 1 zu 2 der vfl bochum gewann gegen
den fc augsburg 5 zu 4 dynamo dresden
unterlag sein pauli 2 zu 3 und waldhof
mannheim union berlin 1 zu 3
fußball weltmeister lukas ernanntes von
bayern münchen muss seine sechsmonatige
haftstrafe in spanien morgen nicht
antreten ein gericht in madrid gab dem
einspruch des französischen
nationalspielers statt und setzte die
strafe für vier jahre auf bewährung aus
zudem muss er eine geldstrafe von 96.000
euro zahlen hintergrund ist eine
verurteilung wegen häuslicher gewalt
2009/10 gegen seine damalige freundin
und heutige frau die gewinnzahlen vom
lotto am mittwoch lauten ohne gewähr 1
16 20 21 25 45 superzahl 6 weitere
gewinnzahlen auf lotto zdf de und im zdf
text
in süditalien haben schwere unwetter
größere schäden angerichtet und der
italienische zivilschutz warnt vor
weiteren überschwemmungen besonders
betroffen catania auf sizilien
ein mann starb in den wassermassen laut
stadtverwaltung bleiben schulen und
nicht essentielle geschäfte vorerst
geschlossen feuerwehren und
rettungskräfte sind im großeinsatz
ab morgen wird in süditalien mit
möglicherweise noch stärkeren
regenfällen gerechnet
er stellte die dinge auf den kopf und
wurde damit weltberühmt der maler
bildhauer und zeichner georg baselitz
zählt zu den berühmtesten künstlern aus
deutschland und zu den höchstbezahlten
inzwischen ist er 83 jahre alt zeit ihm
und seinem in sechs jahrzehnten
geschaffenen werk den roten teppich
auszurollen
das tut jetzt paris die retrospektive
heißt die umfassende ausstellung im
centre pompidou an deren gestaltung
baselitz mitgearbeitet hat selbst ein
bisschen überrascht über die große ehre
die in frankreich erweist heute gab es
noch eine auszeichnung christas hat
baselitz getroffen
in der alt ehrwürdigen akademie deba
wird heute ein neuling eingeführt georg
baselitz ist jetzt mitglied auf
lebenszeit das hier ist sein
persönlicher sessel
nur 63 plätze gibt es für herausragende
künstler jetzt also auch baselitz der
wie er sagt frankreich viel zu verdanken
hat im unterschied zu deutschland war
frankreich vor allem paris voll von
aufregender neuer kunst und von vielen
hier lebenden künstlern hatte ich nie
gehört die stadt bei eine
unerschöpfliche quelle für meine arbeit
das ist nie vergessen geblieben drinnen
zeremonie für draußen kunst von baselitz
zero dom heißt dieses werk ein leeres
verbranntes haus und auch anderswo in
paris wird baselitz der zeit gewürdigt
dass sontra pompidou widmet ihm eine
große retrospektive
da sind der junge der an hitler erinnert
mit seinem riesigen penis damals ein
skandal helden die keine sind skulpturen
wie geschunden all die werke die ein
künstler mit wut im bauch erschafft wut
über die dramen der deutschen geschichte
die er selbst erlebt hat
[Musik]
ich kann nicht lassen die geschichte zu
erzählen ich kann einfach nicht
sagen ich bin frei überhaupt nicht oder
bestehe vielmehr aus erlebnis und alle
meine bei der arbeit nach vorne ist
immer ein rückblick er stellte die kunst
buchstäblich auf den kopf sein
markenzeichen er wollte nicht gefallen
er wollte emotionen
die stärke der werke überträgt sich und
auch die kopf stehenden bilder sind gut
unsere welt steht doch auch kopf
er erlebte den mauerbau den kalten krieg
den mauerfall all das ist in seinen
bildern
seine bilder sind politisch aber total
offen für alle stilrichtungen des
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
ein politischer künstler wollte baselitz
nie sein doch ohne eine gewisse
provokation kann er auch nicht
erinnerung während im alter immer
heftiger allerdings gibt auch eine große
distanz dass dieses tiefe wütend sein
verschwindet zur ausstattung eines
mitglied der akademie die burg gehört
übrigens auch ein ganz persönlicher
liegen auf baselitz klinge ist unter
anderem an kopf stehender mann
eingraviert
so viel von uns wir geben sie jetzt
direkt weiter an antje pieper und das
auslandsjournal das heute über die
verheerende corinna lage in russland
berichtet
und gegen 0.30 meldet sich heute anna
maria schuck mit unserem heute-journal
update so ist es bis morgen
[Musik]
guten abend die wetterlage über europa
ändert sich wenig da gibt es diesen
tiefdruckkomplex der bringt regen nach
galizien nach großbritannien und nach
skandinavien
demgegenüber steht dieses hoch dass
weiter richtung schwarzes meer zieht und
dann gibt es dieses unwetter tief hier
über dem central mittelmeer und das wird
sich jetzt innerhalb der nächsten 24
stunden wohl zu einem medical entwickelt
das ist also eine hurrikan ähnliche
struktur über dem mittelmeer deswegen
medical wird weitere hunderte liter
regen pro quadratmeter bringen und in
sizilien hat es ja bereits ganz heftig
geregnet ganz anderes wetter bei uns in
deutschland da ist es heute nacht häufig
klar und es bildet sich in
süddeutschland erneut nebel im norden
gibt es einige wolkenfelder und die
temperaturen sinken auf plus 3 bis minus
ein grad im süden droht also bodenfrost
sonst bleibt die nacht milder und morgen
liegen die höchsttemperaturen so etwa
zwischen der eifel und niederbayern von
8 bis 14 grad sonst wird es milder mit
15 bis 18 grad verbreitet in
norddeutschland aber auch am alpenrand
und am oberalp das liegt daran dass
morgen strahlen die sonne scheint wenn
nicht gerade nie gestört und dieser
nebel der könnte sich wirklich zäh
halten hier an der donau sehr viel
sonniger ist es in norddeutschland die
paar wolkenfelder hier im nordosten die
werden schon nachmittags weggezogen
seien am freitag sieht es noch mal ganz
ähnlich aus am wochenende allerdings
wird es von westen etwas unbeständiger
da fällt dann auch mal regen an den
temperaturen ändert sich wenig guten
abend